Grand Rapids Michigan huh
nicer than I thought it was gonna be
because you don't hear about Grand
Rapids when you hear about Michigan you
hear about Detroit you hear about flint
and so I was expecting hell when I came
here I thought it was going to be I Am
Legend this is also I swear to God I
told a waitress at brunch today where I
was performing and she was like oh
Billy's I got roofied there I was like
God damn it dude
where am I going dude she was like yeah
it's a thing
I do need to watch my drink I'm too
little Defender you know I mean half a
roofie will give me
I gotta go as soon as I said roofies was
like they're on to me
so if you walk out this door I'm calling
the cops I'm telling you
right now
I sincerely hope you just have to take
it